hi friends I hope you had a good
Christmas and New Year we are kicking
off 2019 with what might be the best
episode that I've ever recorded I know I
do say that a lot it's a running joke
but this one genuinely could be it Alex
Hutchinson is a writer journalist and an
endurance athlete recently wrote a book
called endure mind body and the
curiously elastic limits of human
performance I think anyone who has ever
gone for a run has thought to themselves
what makes some of us quit while others
continue and just how much of human
performance is dictated by the mind and
how much by the body it's a fundamental
question which anyone who has ever taken
part in a physical pursuit has
considered and today alex is going to
take us through exactly what he's
uncovered I'm absolutely certain that
this is going to be a massive benefit to
a lot of listeners if it is to you
please pop it into your gym Facebook
group or send it to some friends that
you know would really appreciate the
insights that Alex gives us this could
genuinely be a game changer for a lot of
athletes performances as we move into
2019 so pound the share button if you
would be so kind don't forget it
subscribe if you are new to the channel
it would make me very happy indeed and
if you're a regular listener please go
and give me five stars wherever you are
tuned in now let's go and improve our
endurance
[Music]
alit's welcome to modern wisdom how are
you I'm good thanks for having me on I
appreciate brilliant
so I'm specifically excited about
today's podcast not least because my
endurance sucks so I am hoping as I'm
sure many of the listeners are to find
some strategies that can improve our
endurance and also I think probably
define and better understand what
endurance is because as far as I'm
concerned it's something that I work on
quite a lot and sometimes I feel like
it's good and then sometimes I've I feel
like I might have never trained before
in my life yeah I mean in hey so I'll
confess I started with a very narrow
definition of endurance yeah I was I've
been a runner my whole life so I was
thinking very narrowly and of endurance
as kind of how fast can you run a long
race but I've come to to think of
endurance as a much broader thing and in
fact I'll jump right in with the
definition that I ended up using in the
book which is the endurance is the
struggle to continue against a mounting
desire to stop so it's it's it's
something that takes place over time and
it can be you know we can be talking
about mental endurance physical
endurance you know at work or hate
during exercise or whatever the case may
be but what I'll end up arguing is that
fundamentally that struggle is is the
same and the struggle to continue you
know to keep studying if for a like an
exam or something is actually the same
mental struggle that goes on when you're
running a marathon and you're trying to
force yourself to maintain a pace that
is unpleasant that's a very artistic
definition I think much more artistic
than how would a very artistic but yeah
it's definitely not where I stood I
started out thinking that it you know my
definition of endurance would be you
know the maximum amount of oxygen that
your lungs can transport to you and I
was expecting mid-range exercise but
that definition I you know I didn't just
pull it out of out of let's say my head
it's actually from a scientific paper
from a guy at the University of Kent who
studies endurance he's the head of the
endurance research group there
and that's what he concluded that this
is what the fundamental you know bedrock
of endurance is that it's not about
oxygen it's not about muscle fibers it's
about a mental struggle and that
ultimately when you're whether you're
running a marathon or again in some
other aspect of your life struggling to
continue against something that's
unpleasant it's it's it's how you face
that struggle mentally and it's your
it's your struggle to continue against
that mounting desire to stop that really
matters so that's that's the scientific
definition even though it sounds like
you know I was reading a poem about
endurance or something yeah so where
does endurance begin what did you what
did you first begin to look at and where
does the book start yeah so actually the
I mentioned that I've you know I've been
a runner for most of my life and I
actually I competed for the Canadian
national team for about a decade as a
cross-country runner and track and field
runner so this started as a sort of
personal quest for me and actually
through the what the place I started the
book is a single race that I had back in
the mid 1990s when I was a university
student where I was I was trying to
break the four-minute barrier for 1500
meters which is a little bit shorter
than a mile so it's kind of it's like a
418 mile so pretty you know yeah it's a
poor-man's four-minute mile barrier
let's say it's not as fast as the
four-minute mile but significant and and
and I actually was stuck at 401 or 402
for four years during high school and
then University so I had the sense that
I had approached the true limits of my
endurance that maybe I could run 359 but
that was about all that I'd be able to
I'd been running 401 or 402 year after
year and I ended up I ran a race and
what happened is the timekeeper gave me
the wrong splits basically I was I went
you know when you run in a track race
every lap there's a timekeeper who will
call out how fast you're going so you
have a sense of whether you're on pace
and and he was calling out splits that
were about three or four seconds off and
and basically fooled me into thinking
that I was running way faster than I was
and so after about a third of the way
through the race I you know I was having
this like wow this this is way faster
than I think I'm going and yet I feel
really good and
I had the sensation I was having the
greatest day of my life and so I just
kind of went for it I really unshackled
myself from my pre-race expectations and
ended up running 352 which was like a
like believe me after four years of
running the same times over and over
again it was it was absolutely
mind-blowing and and what then happened
is that I was totally altered I never
struggled to break four minutes again
and in fact I then ran 349 then in my
next race and 344 in my next race so all
of a sudden I went from like a mediocre
college runner to to you know running in
that summer's Olympic Trials and so that
for me was the real foundation of hang
on the limits of my ability when I'm up
against what seems like physical limits
there's something more there because I
you know my muscles didn't change or you
know and my my lungs and my heart and
all these other things none of that
changed dramatically over the course of
those few weeks but being tricked
somehow unlocked some reserves that were
otherwise there so I you know I don't
want to oversimplify that you know and
from that moment on I knew I would but
it kind of it kind of laid the
groundwork for me of thinking there's
something more to this it's not we're
not just like cars where you know you
press down the gas tank and your speed
is a function of you know how many
cylinders you have in your engine and
and how much gas is in the tank instead
it's something much more complex and I
think for anyone who has tried to push
their limits in any in any capacity you
pretty soon realized that it's not just
some sort of mathematical thing that I'm
capable of X and that's that's exactly
what I'm capable of that that there's
there's more to it and that the brain
plays a role in dictating in ways that
we're not even aware of the blur the
brain plays a role in setting our
physical limits so that was the start
for me of trying to understand well how
does the how do the mind and body work
together to create what we feel as
physical limits that's a very poignant
way to start your journey I suppose it's
gonna be something that's gonna that's
gonna really kick it home that you made
such a such a marked difference in your
performance purely based on the fact
that you had this mental barrier so
what's the what's kind of the
established understanding of the limits
of endurance at
yeah so well it's in flux I would say
that it's it's it turns out that it's an
exciting area to to write about in terms
of scientific research because there are
a lot of differing views right now in
fact you know that one of the sort of
mixed benefits of the modern world is
that you can go on Twitter and follow a
bunch of the scientists who are at the
forefront of research in this area and
discover that they actually really hate
each other and you can follow their
ideas but also follow their like their
there's their sort of schoolyard insults
of each other so it's it's it's an area
in flux but the way the way I would
frame it is is for most of the 20th
century there was this attempt to
understand the human body sort of more
or less as a machine that and there was
a huge amount of progress made was made
throughout the 20th century of
understanding all the parts of the human
machine how muscles contract what fuels
them what are the different ways muscles
can work you know the cardiovascular
system and and and all of this with this
sort of unspoken assumption that if you
could understand all the parts of the
Machine you would fully understand the
workings of the human body that you so
just like we can we know how much gas
goes into the gas tank of a car and we
know how far that car can go that you
could calculate you know and actually
there are equations that they'd sort of
were perfected in the in the early 1990s
of if I know what's called my vo2 max
which is a measure of oxygen capacity
and my running economy which is kind of
like the fuel economy of a car and my
lactate threshold which tells how much
lactate which is a metabolic byproduct
of building up in my body anyway if you
if you take these three quantities which
you can test in the lab you can plug
them into an equation and it will say
you should be able to run a marathon in
so many hours so many minutes and so
many seconds and so it's a very
deterministic model of like we know the
parameters of this machine therefore we
know the limits of its endurance how
accurate is that proven to be so in the
big picture it's it's pretty good like
if if I take if you take a hundred
people off the street send them to a lab
have
complete those tests then you'll be able
to rank them in order of how fast
they're gonna run a marathon with
reasonably good accuracy but you're
never gonna know exactly so so you're
gonna be able to tell the difference
between to someone who can run a
marathon in two thirty two it to Anna
two hours 30 minutes and someone who can
run the marathon in three hours and
maybe even two hours 45 minutes but when
you take a bunch of people who are at a
similar level let's say the field at the
Olympics everyone there is fit and
everyone there has trained hard has
talent the lab values will tell you
absolutely nothing about who's going to
win the race and that's the realization
people came to that there's once you
once you get rid of the obvious like you
know that you know the guy who's been
training his whole life is gonna be
fitter than the guy who's never run a
step that's that yeah yeah the the
equations in the lab tests can tell you
the difference between those two guys
but you can't tell can't tell the
difference between a field of relatively
equally matched people I guess so it's
not sufficiently high fidelity to be
able to narrow down the the real sort of
very close close-knit
yeah exactly so I don't want to dismiss
it and say this this stuff is useless
because it's not it tells you a lot it
just doesn't tell you everything and and
you know where things get get serious
and interesting is not whether Joe
Olympian can beat Joe Sixpack it's it's
who's gonna actually win the Olympics or
whatever or am I are from a personal
perspective am i you know in shape to
run a new best that's better than I ran
last year wet and and the lab tests
don't have like as he said they don't
have enough fidelity to see that sort of
fine grain and so it was in the late
1990s that that people some scientists
started to challenge this sort of
orthodoxy there's a guy named Tim Noakes
I was a South African sports scientist
who is extremely influential extremely
controversial he's uh these days he's
probably best known that he's become a
real advocate of low carb high fat diets
and writing some very provocative stuff
about how everyone else is you know part
of the yeah
yeah an idiot and a corrupt paid off
idiot so there's someone shilling for
the plastic companies all the rice
companies are giving backhanders to the
the rest of the endurance researchers to
make sure that everyone stays on a
carbohydrate binge yeah you're
essentially quoting directly from what
he looks almost exactly what what he
says in ink I love him already he wrote
a whole book about the height sports
hydration where he basically called out
by name most of the leading sports
nutrition researchers in the world and
said they were all paid off by Gatorade
and the thing is there's some truth to
what he says but it's not I think he
takes it too far I think they're I think
their research anyway with this this is
a bit of a rabbit hole but the point is
he's very provocative he may not get all
the details right but he sure as heck
folks forces people to think carefully
about their assumptions and and so in
the late 90s he started to say hey this
sort of focus on the body is missing
something important and it's not just
enough to say well you know of course
you have to be motivated too or you have
to try hard that you have to think about
the brain and the body as one system
together and he proposed an idea that he
called the central governor model which
was this idea that no matter how hard
you try you can't push to your true
physical limits because if you did if
you push to the point where you know he
really couldn't get enough oxygen in
then your heart and your and/or your
brain would be in trouble and you'd keel
over and die essentially and so he said
we're hardwired with this sort of
central governor a central protective
mechanism to always hold back a little
bit of reserve that the brain is
deciding where your where your limits
are for your own safety and whether
that's strictly speaking true or not I'm
not sure and I don't think anybody is
sure but what that did is spark a whole
kind of revolution and reevaluation of
the role of the brain and limits and so
when I got interested in this topic
which was about 10 or 12 years ago the
whole field was an upheaval as people
were arguing about this central governor
idea what role the brain played and that
is sort of continued to this day there's
still a bunch of rival theories and the
arguing about how the brain should be
incorporated but overall I would say
there's a there's a sort of
underlying consensus which is that yeah
the you know when you go out and if I if
I put you on a treadmill set the speed
at a given pace and say run until you
fall off the back of the treadmill the
moment you fall off the back of the
treadmill or the moment you say stop the
treadmill before I fall off the back
it's fundamentally a decision that
you're making and it's not based on
there's no measurement I can take
whether it's your heart rate or your
your breathing rate or your body
temperature your lactate levels there's
no measurement I can take it will tell
me when you're gonna fall off the back
of the treadmill reliably but there is
one question I can ask you which is how
hard does this feel and when you get to
the point where you say this feels like
about a 10 out of 10 on effort boom
you're off the back of the treadmill and
so it's your it's your your brains
processing of all these signals from
your body and processing of how you're
feeling in general processing of how you
slept last night and and how you're
getting on with your partner and so on
your brain is processing all that
information into one number which or one
sensation which is how hard it feels and
that is the ultimate sort of final
answer in terms of where the limits of
your endurance are so that's that's I
think it's not universally agreed upon
but I think that's where the field is
moving now in contrast to the 20th
century
it's a machine if we know your lactate
and your breathing rate and stuff we'll
be able to dictate your limits I get
that completely I recently did a podcast
with some of the coaches from Reebok
CrossFit Tyneside up here in Newcastle
and as a part of that I asked them the
question which essentially you're moving
through the answer of now which was if I
put a bar that is five Keeler's above
your PB in front of you and I tell you
that you need to pick it up there's a a
chance that you may be able to pick it
up but the difference between you
lifting it and not lifting it really
lies within your mind and what I was
fascinated by and we couldn't come up
with the solution but you may be able to
give us some solve at some spot light on
this is what the mechanism is that works
on whether or not you pick the bar up or
whether you don't pick the bar up how
you how your brain is able to choose how
much of your body's performance gets
deployed if that makes sense
yeah totally well so as the first thing
I'll say is if if you put the bar that
with five kilos extra on it and if I
don't tell you that it has those five
kilos so that you think it's just the
same load that you've lifted before
that's going to raise your chances
dramatically of lifting it if you
believe that yeah this is I've done this
before of course I can do this then
you'll have a much greater chance of
doing it is that due to hormonal profile
in the body is that because of just a
psychological bias that we've got yeah I
think well it's
mcdeere's a mix of things going on
fundamentally what's going on is your
brain is sending a signal to your
muscles telling how many muscle fibers
should be recruited which muscle fibers
in what order and so it's a very very
complex process you know if you're doing
say a deadlift there's I can't remember
there's something like 13 different
muscles there's 17 different muscles
that have to contract in a very specific
order so just just saying just
contracting more isn't always the right
answer but contracting in a way that you
know if you don't think you're going to
be able to do it then you're already
perhaps contracting the in a pattern
that is defensive so that when you fail
you're not going to hurt yourself
but in doing so you make it less likely
that you succeed whereas if the
neuromuscular signaling is proceeding
with the assumption that you're going to
be able to do it you're maybe giving
yourself a little edge because you're
not holding back with the fear of
failure and that that probably ties into
your story from your 1,500 meter run as
well absolutely I think there's a big
connection and you know like when we
start talking about muscle strength it's
it's interesting because obviously
lifting something once is different from
sustaining something for an hour or for
four minutes or whatever the case may be
but there's a lot of parallels and
there's a lot of literature so I have a
chapter in the book called muscle where
I try and sort of disentangle so what
does it mean to be limited by your
muscle strength what does it mean is is
is fundamentally what happens when you
reach failure is that is it that you're
you know your muscle fibers simply
aren't able to contract in a way that
completes the the motion and it turns
out to be just like with with sort of
marathon running it turns out to be a
much slippery slope to try and figure
out what your limits are so there's
there's some famous study
from back in the early 1960s and one of
them what they did is that they had
volunteers doing a maximum kind of
biceps curl contraction once every
minute so they were just supposed to do
it all out don't save anything just once
a minute give us your your maximum curl
for a couple seconds and they were
measuring the force produced and then
before one of the the lifts they had one
of the researchers snuck up behind the
volunteers and fired a gun in their ears
basically scared the crap out of them
and all of a sudden of course their
their strength their maximum strength
suddenly goes up by something like eight
or ten percent so and you know we sort
of understand this intuitively as a
fight-or-flight response like they were
completely scared at that moment a
fraction of a second before they were
lift so BAM they they they're able to
produce more force now they could get a
similar effect by injecting adrenaline
or injecting some some stimulants I
think it was F at Rennes or something I
can remember what the stiffness
stimulant was so so there are chemical
ways of sort of altering what's going on
in in in the brain which in turn changes
how much of your muscle force you know
if you think in evolutionary terms at
that moment when the bear is chasing you
or whatever the case may be then
whatever safety circuitry is hardwired
into your body it's it's it's a good
it's good for you if that circuitry is
somewhat flexible and could say you know
what we're we're gonna disable this
everything yeah yeah let's not say let's
not save this for another day so that
and you see that with with with pain too
like then the same thing if you're you
know if you're a deer being chased by a
wolf and you trip and break your leg
it's not the time to say oh I need to
lie down and then let this leg get
better you're just gonna keep running
even if you break break though even if
that like smells worse yeah so there's
there's these mechanisms that affect
both how we perceive what's going on
like pain pain perception but also how
we send muscles Harrisons signals to our
brains to brain to our muscles and those
can be mediated by emotional responses
and by hormones and also just by like we
were saying before like deception then
there are
where they they do exactly the sort of
thing they tell you you're gonna lift
one weight and you're lifting another
weight or they tell you you have to
you're racing against your own best
performance but really they have you
racing in virtual reality against your
own best performance plus 1% or plus 2%
and they find that if you add a percent
or two and you have the belief that you
can beat that
you think it's just your own best
performance from last time you were in
the lab then you beat it until unless
it's changed too much if you speed up
this this virtual reality reputation
representation of yourself by 5% then
that's too far and you're trying to race
against yourself but you know something
is wrong and you end up getting
discouraged so so there's it's never
like do all of this or do this thing
always works but depending on the
context there are various ways you can
tweak what you expect to go on in your
brain and use that as a way of doing
more than you were previously capable of
yeah what's interesting that there's a
funny story I'm not too too sure how
much truths in it but a couple of my
friends of firefighters and they say a
lot of the time if there's been car
accidents and stuff and mothers have
been known to be to have incredible
bursts of strength when they're
concerned about their baby in a car and
they've been able to pull handles harder
than they would be able to and you know
move things out of the way because
they've got this mortal fear these
situation that they're in and that kind
of ties back to the the bear scenario
that you described and then the same for
anyone who's ever watched a powerlifting
competition if you look at power lifters
before they step up to the plate they're
sniffing smelling salts that take your
face off and they're getting their
friends to slap them on the back of the
the back of the neck you say if someone
if you went through that in a normal
day-to-day like just normal day-to-day
life you'd want to go to bed for a
little bit but you know these guys are
electing to do it because they think
that it's going to prime their mind into
a state where they can recruit more from
their body yeah totally and so that's
one of the things I looked into is this
ok is it true that you know a scared mom
could lift a car off there crushed baby
and if you if you look through news
archives you find story after story like
this but in there of course it never
happens in the lab because you know
you're not allowed to put a baby under a
car in the lab it's just they just don't
don't go for it but so I was trying to
sort of figure this out
and I found I ended up finding a story
probably the most plausible story I
could find happened about 12 years ago
in Arizona a guy who was a cyclist was
hit by a car and strapped under the
wheels and the guy the guy who came and
so reportedly according to eyewitnesses
this guy came and lifted the car up so
that someone else could pull the the the
cyclist out from under the car and it so
it turns out this guy was actually this
you know this guy was not a guy who
looked like me he was a guy who actually
could deadlift he had a best-of I can't
remember something like seven hundred
pounds in the gym he was a strong strong
old boy then he was the guy that you
wanted if you're trapped under a car you
want that guy yeah he was the right guy
and so the question the question is my
time this is what I've been training for
my entire life and and in that moment he
undoubtedly did more than he had ever
done because one of the cool postscripts
to the story is you know it all happened
he got they got the guy out he's driving
home later a lot that night and he
realized as a mouth feels kind of funny
he gets home and realizes he's cracked
eight teeth or something like that so he
was clenching his mouth so hard while
doing this lift and so you know you
start to do the math and say so the car
was a Chevy Camaro it's like okay how
much does a Chevy Camaro way well it
weighs something like fourteen hundred
kilos or something depending on the
model year and so that's a lot more than
and then you say well what's the world
record for a deadlift well I I I did
some some digging on this and so the
unofficial record is actually it was set
at though the world's strongman
competition in I think it was 1982 a guy
lifted a guy named Tom McGee lifted I
can't remember the exact numbers in the
vicinity of eleven hundred and fifty
pounds so like 500 kilos of cheddar
cheese it was in news it was in New
Zealand so they had these you can find
the video on YouTube it's amazing these
like it's just stacks of cheddar cheese
and and he lifts it up and just like
there's a big gap between 500 kilos and
you know 1400 kilos and then you start
to do the physics well okay you don't
have to lift the whole car up you just
have to leave her it up on its back
wheels so maybe you're lifting a core
you know half its weight or third of its
weight and then there's the shocks how
much lift are you getting from the shock
absorbers so the final scientific answer
that I come up with is I don't
really no maybe you know maybe it could
happen you can and and and there's also
I ended up digging into the old Soviet
athletic literature there's some studies
from back in the 50s and 60s in the
Soviet Union trying to understand what
the ultimate limits of weightlifters are
and they concluded that you know a
typical person can access about 80% of
their maximum muscle strength whereas a
trained weightlifter can maybe get to
90% in competition and then that you
know I had someone I had a friend of
mine who speaks Russian you know
translate some of these papers for me
but it's pretty obscure where they get
those numbers from what the third one
they're just kind of pulling them out of
their ears but the bottom line is under
the right circumstances it seems pretty
fair to say that you can often find a
little bit more strength you can't
necessarily find double your strength or
something like you're you know you're
not gonna be able to lift that car over
your head or anything like that but
maybe you're gonna be able to get it get
an extra 10 20 percent of what you're
already capable of and then maybe
that'll be enough to get the baby out
from under the car whatever the case may
be so what we're saying is that the
brain plays a very prominent role in
eliciting as much of your performance as
as you can yeah exactly and so the
important thing is that it's the brain
doesn't turn you into Superman the brain
so if you if you're if you're asked to
bet on you know a mentally strong person
who weighs 30 kilos and a sort of lazy
guy who's who's you know huge and and
with enormous muscles the guy with
enormous muscles is gonna be stronger
he's gonna lift up more but even even if
he's getting less out of himself but so
it you know mental strength isn't gonna
allow you you know David to beat Goliath
yeah but but for most of us the the
fundamental thing is trying to come
close closer to our own limits to to you
know to get the most out of ourselves so
that we can or if you're in competition
to beat people who are roughly on our
level not six six levels above and in
that case that's where the mind comes in
that it
it determines whether you're gonna get
90% or 95% of yourself not whether
you're gonna get 500% oh yeah that makes
complete sense
so what during your discovery during
over the research for the book did you
discover helps with moving the brain
towards a more efficient deployment of
the body's capabilities because everyone
who is listening that trains will
understand the concept of progressive
overload for muscular training and
although I haven't spent an awful lot of
time running I'm going to presume that
the same will be done that you'll run a
long distance then split that up into
smaller distances and move you split
forward and have little breaks and you
know so on and so forth so is there an
equivalent for the brain yeah well there
are a bunch of different ways you can go
some of which I recommend and some of
which I don't what one of the things I
tried just for kicks
well writing the book there's something
there's something called transcranial
direct current stimulation which is
basically you take a 9-volt battery and
a couple of electrodes and you attach it
to your head and you run some some
current through your brain it's a weak
current so it's a and let me just
reiterate here this is one of the just
in case of any do this is one of this
things I'm not suggesting you do but if
they I mean all joking aside as far as
anyone knows it's safe but if you pick
though if you put the electrodes in the
right place you can moderate or change
the activity of the neurons that are
responsible for your perception of
effort so you can make a given level of
exercise feel a little bit easier and as
we were saying earlier if it feels
easier you can do it for longer or you
can increase you can do it harder
because how it feels is really what
matters so over the last five years
there have been a bunch of studies
showing that this technique you do about
10 minutes of electric brain stimulation
it changes how your neurons fire for
about an hour so you get this temporary
alteration in how hard exercise feels
and as a result you're able to push
harder and achieve more and there were
athletes using this technique at the
Winter Olympics this year is the 2018
Winter Olympics
and walking around with 9-volt batteries
and substituting well are using them in
training and and there were you know
they've been professional sports teams
experimenting with it there's a Silicon
Valley startup that makes
noise-canceling halo of scene that's
that's the one I'm talking about and
that's what I tried
well while writing the book it didn't
actually work for me in the sense that
I'm bald and apparently mice you know
the the the tough weather in Canada has
toughened my scalp to a degree that I I
really had trouble making electrical
contact with the spikes that are
supposed to deliver the currents is that
the controller just kept saying
insufficient electrical contact and I'm
like man I'm digging these spikes into
my head I'm deaf with like 24 little red
divots on my head for the rest of the
day yeah so so anyway all of which is
the point here is that there are ways of
directly manipulating the brain that
alter your perception of effort and
altering your perception of effort
improves your performance which which is
to me is a cool principle because it
shows that you haven't changed anything
below you're below the neck all you're
doing is manipulating how your neurons
communicate with each other and all of a
sudden your physical limits have changed
that's interesting so effort is is a big
mediator there so when you're doing RP
and you say rate of perceived exertion
is a nine but if the next day you then
felt that that nine was an eight you'd
be able to move more that's a hundred
percent that that is that is the
fundamental truth or at least theory
that that that is at the forefront of
exercise physiology right now that that
that our PE the rating of perceived
exertion is the master controller of
what you're capable of Wow tell us more
about that so I mean it is just for
listeners who aren't familiar with that
rating of perceived assertion it's it's
it's a very simple concept and there's
you can it's an if I if I'm doing an
exercise and someone asked me hey how
hard is this exercise on a scale of you
can either use a scale of 6 to 20 or a
scale of 1 to 10 so let's just say the 1
to 10 because it's a little simpler and
I say that's a 7 out of 10 then they'll
say ok that's great and they know then
roughly how long I'll be able to
continue doing that and once I get to 10
out of 10 that's it by definition I'm
done if I'm saying this is as hard as I
can go then they know that I'm not going
to be able to keep going there now
people first hear about this they they
kind of think well that's sort of an
imperfect rough vague description of how
you're feeling and you know what one
person will call seven out of ten
another person might call six out of ten
and you know that's all true but the
fact remains that it turns out to be a
really reliable guide to how how what
you're capable of doing and and people
are go well it's not as reliable or
accurate as your lactate levels or your
you know your your whatever else
occasion your heart rate or your your
breathing rate or all these other things
your your rating of perceived exertion
incorporates all the media it's mediated
by all of those things yeah so it's it's
it's we're talking about a different
level of explanation of course your your
heart rate matters but it only matters
insofar as it makes Xers are is
associated with exercise feeling harder
and what's the the key thing is that yes
rating of perceived assertion reflects
all those things that are going on in
your body but it also reflects what's
going on in your mind and that's what's
what are in your brain and that's why
you can alter your rating of perceived
exertion using something like electric
brain stimulation and then you're able
to keep going or lift more or run faster
even though you haven't changed anything
about what's going on in your muscles or
your heart or your lungs and so there's
been a number of studies that have
demonstrated that to be the case if you
find a way of manipulating perceived
exertion then you've effectively found
it found a way of changing your physical
limits that's kind of it's it's a super
powerful insight because if it's true
then it changes your whole perspective
on what are my limits because when you
feel like you've hit your physical
limits it doesn't feel like it reflects
you know your feelings or your
perceptions it's like no I I swear to
you my legs could not take another step
and and what this research is saying is
yeah they could have yeah if a lion had
jumped out from behind a tree and
started chasing you you would have taken
a little bit more motivation yeah and of
course you know in some circumstances
let's say it's the Olympic final
motivation is already pretty near to
maximal so it's not like you people
aren't trying hard but even in that
situation the fundamental determinant is
that the reason you stop isn't that your
legs are completely incapable it's that
you've reached the point where it's
absolutely at your maximum
a bill a effort it's it's as hard as you
can push I love I love the idea of this
I often think about the very very
granular nature the straw that broke the
camel's back so to speak about just how
much more could you have squeezed out
you know okay so the line jumps out and
then oh my god the lines attacking your
wife and then oh my god then your mum
your mum's behind your wife and you know
I mean like you just how much more could
we layer on top
I do think about this quite a lot it's
an interesting thought experiment which
it would appear is actually existing in
real experiments as well so I wanted
clarify they've never actually done the
lion thing with the mother the workplace
needs to be done we need to get some
funding and then it'll be fine
so I want to talk about how some
specific factors can define your limits
because we we will get on to some
tactics for how you can improve the mind
game so to speak but there are things
that your mind will detect so pain
oxygen heat thirst and fuel I think the
the ones that you define quite heavily
is that right yeah yeah there's there's
a bunch of those and I think there's
maybe a couple others like heat or I
can't you know so basically what I tried
to do in the book is I tried to sort of
attack my this claim that we've just
been talking about that it's all
perception of effort and say okay well
what happens when we really push some of
these things that limit us to to their
absolute extremes like what are you
perceiving as well you're saying you're
talking about perception of effort well
what is the perception it's like now
it's not effort effort isn't a thing
it's like okay it's a combination of
like fatigue and pain and discomfort and
and like you say the heat and the sweat
and the oxygen and it you need to break
them down right and that's what you
that's what you've done here yeah well
and and what is effort is that actually
a deep question that maybe we can we can
swipe out a little bit there there's
there's lots of arguments about this and
and and there's researchers who argue
very strongly that it's different from
pain and it's different from fatigue and
what it actually refract reflects is how
hard your brain
is working to send signals to your
muscles so the harder your brain has to
work you perceive this as a struggle to
continue against a mounting desire to
stop and I went and so it's it's a
distinct so there's studies that try and
separate pain from effort so they they
they first they they have you get a
sense of what pain is they force you to
dip your hand in an ice bucket and and
until you can't and you say when you
can't when when you pull that your hand
out to the ice bucket they say okay
that's ten out of ten pain
now I want you to think differently
about so pain versus just effort how
hard is it to keep peddling that bike
they put you on your bike they have your
pedal to exhaustion and what they find
is at the moment you give up what people
tend to be saying on average is yeah oh
that this really hurts it's a pain of
like six or seven out of ten but my
effort is a ten out of ten so you're
giving up it does hurt six or seven out
of ten pain is bad yeah but it's not ten
out of ten it's the it's the effort that
reaches its peak which is something
different depending on you know it's
defining it as something distinct from
from pain so anyway that's a bit of a
rabbit hole I don't want to like believe
at that point but it but the question of
what effort is is an interesting one and
it's not obvious it's something that
people are arguing about but to actually
answer your question so yeah what are
all these things that go into formula to
creating the perception of effort oh
it's creating the perception of limit as
well isn't it yeah yeah what defines
your limit within these contour within
different contexts I suppose and of
course I you know I've been rambling on
about how limits are all just sort of a
sort of creation of you know your
perception of effort but of course look
if I don't if I lock you in a room and
don't give you water for a week
you're gonna die and that's that's not a
figment of your imagination you're you
actually are gonna run out of fluid
yeah and far earlier than that you you
know if you're running a marathon and
you don't a hot day and you don't drink
any water you're not gonna die but
you're gonna be probably performing
sub-optimally because your Bloods gonna
be getting a lot thicker because you've
lost so much fluid to to sweat and so
all this of how hard you want to push
yeah yeah it doesn't matter you can you
can be the you know the the toughest guy
in town but medon't or similarly if you
let's say you don't eat any breakfast
you don't eat let's say you don't
for 24 hours and you trying to run a
marathon well you're gonna be out of gas
in the same way that a car can run out
of gas and it doesn't really matter how
tough you are
your performance isn't gonna be as good
as it would be if you had a full load of
fuel and similarly it you know if if
it's you know 35 degrees and sunny
you're not gonna run a marathon as fast
as you would if it was 10 degrees and
overcast and again nothing to do with
mental toughness so so those are the
sort of counter arguments that you have
to think about and say okay but Alex
before you write a book that that claims
that in the limits of endurance are all
in your head what what is it what do all
these other things tell us these forms
of limits what happens when you run out
of oxygen if you're free diving or
climbing a mountain like Mount Everest
and so let me just give you the broad
overall conclusion which is that all
those things are capable of slowing you
down and but in keeping with what we've
been saying the way they slow you down
is that they make things feel harder
they give you basically a I don't know
if in Britain you think of or is it
orange lights and red lights or yellow
lights and red lights yeah so let's call
it they give you orange lights they are
cautioning you that hey you're gonna get
in some trouble if you keep going
without drinking and so we're gonna make
this feel harder even though your body
isn't failing yet we're gonna make it
feel harder to try and force you to slow
down so that unless you in unless you
take some fuel or get some water
whatever the case is that the thing is
that you're missing so these things do
slow us down but the way they slow us
down is not because you're you know
you're out of water and therefore your
body isn't functioning right it's
because your brain is perceiving the
short you know with the increase in body
temperature or the reduction in fluids
in your body as a potential problem and
it's raising your perception of effort
now if you persist and ignore the orange
lights then yeah you're gonna hit a red
light you're gonna you're gonna run out
of fuel you're gonna or you you're gonna
overheat and have to stop or whatever
the case may be but those red lights are
only hit if you ignore the orange lights
and the orange lights are mediated by
again by your brain so
yes there are real physical limits of
course you know of course if you if you
if you don't drink or eat anything
you're gonna you're not gonna be able to
perform the same as if you do but the
the way in most cases the way those
those limits act is that by acting on
the brain rather than by making your
muscles stop working or whatever so it's
acting on the the RPE again essentially
exactly exams so stupid that I didn't
think about this before but that the
rate of perceived exertion or how much
effort you feel you're putting in is
this macro figure which collects all of
the different inputs that your body is
feeling so like you say you know you've
come and you had an argument with the
wife last night but you had a good
night's sleep well but you didn't drink
enough what you ate enough and you know
all of these things are collated into
your body determining what is the
current what is the current status quo
inside of me at the moment and therefore
how much how difficult or easy am I
going to allow this particular level of
discomfort to feel as I as I move
through all this this particular
exercise to feel but that's exactly it
and to me it's it's a really powerful
way of thinking about things you know I
I want to you know do the obligatory
step back and say there are plenty of
scientists who will say that that's a
bunch of crap there's still lots of
debate and and some who still would say
no the body is a machine the mind
doesn't matter so it's it's an area of
research but to me that's a it's it's a
very convincing explanation it makes
intuitive sense and there's also some
really fascinating research that kind of
backs this up and says no this is what's
happening why don't one of my favorite
examples is they had cyclists do an
endurance test and they flashed pictures
of either smiling faces or frowning
faces on the wall in front of them but
only for 16 milliseconds at a time which
is like a tenth the length of a blink so
the cyclists didn't even know there were
faces flashing on the wall in front of
them but it was just enough that they
could perceive it unconsciously and it
sort of changes your mood that you see
someone smiling it unconsciously makes
you feel a little bit happier or if you
see someone frowning it makes you feel a
little less happy and what they found is
in a
very subtle way that changed their
reported perception of effort as they
were cycling this endurance test and
changed their performance by 12% and so
it goes back to this idea that it's this
your perception of effort is integrating
everything that's going on it's not just
integrating what your lactate levels
aren't what your you know body
temperature is it's also integrating how
you're feeling about the world and so
you're asking yourself the question can
I keep going for another 10 seconds if
you're feeling a little bit better about
things in general the answer is yes so
this is what the kind of thing that I
I'm a sort of very skeptical guy by
nature and I sort of have always ignored
sports psychology and not really put
much stock in it when I started to look
at this research it made me think oh
wait you know this is these are these
are results from scientific labs really
quantifying the fact that what's going
on in your brain matters everyone at
home who has ever done a workout which
has got to push them towards their
limits will know that some days it goes
in and it you can go into the gym and it
feels everything just clicks for
whatever reason it is your rate of
perceived exertion it's like it's like
the ceilings just been lifted and then
there's other days when you go in and
like gravity just feels so so much
heavier then it should do and I think
working off that rate of perceived
exertion it makes so much intuitive
sense to me I really like as a concept
so I wanted to talk one of the things
that I certainly thought would have been
a big impact would have been pain and
discomfort I think did you look into
pain and discomfort and and such I I did
in fact there's a whole chapter in the
book on pain when it was a fun one so
yeah so again I know I'm sort of saying
this over and over again but I'll say
the there is disagreement among
scientists and in fact this is one of my
favorite examples of disagreement
because there's two guys at the
University of Kent
a guy named Sam well Mark Cora and a guy
named Alexis major who are colleagues
and Mark aura is basically the leading
advocate of effort is the be-all and
end-all and may
is the leading researcher on the role of
pain in exercise and so they have
totally did you know different views on
what is more important working out with
the same University as well yeah and
what's great and what's what's what I
think is really really wonderful and
speaks well of both of them is that they
collaborate on studies and they do them
together and it did and you know they
may disagree about the interpretation of
the results but they're they're trying
to tease apart the relative role of pain
and effort and so my reading of it is
that pain matters it definitely matters
the more unpleasant something is the
worst you'll do at it and but that pain
is subordinate to effort pain mostly
matters because if something is painful
you'll it'll it influence your sense of
effort and you'll feel like it's harder
but in a sense it doesn't matter what's
subordinate to what because the the
point is since pain contributes to that
feeling how you handle pain will
influence how you perform and there's
some really interesting research showing
that you know the difference between
athletes and non-athletes in terms of
how they manage pain and how that
affects their performance so there have
been a lot of studies over the years
that show that athletes have a greater
pain tolerance than non-athletes so you
take some arbitrary way of inflicting
pain whether it's with blood pressure
cuffs or ice bats or pressure you know
sticking poking people or whatever the
case may be what you find is that first
of all what you find is that their pain
sensitivity is the same athletes and
non-athletes it's not that athletes have
some sort of magical way that they don't
feel pain in fact so the threshold at
which they say hey that hurts stop that
you bastard yeah is roughly the same
they feel pain the same it's just that
the athletes are willing to sit there
and endure it for much longer they'll be
they look they'll say okay keep on going
yeah it's okay it's okay it hurts but I
can tolerate it and and their maximum
threshold is much higher so the next
question then is is this because that's
the people who become athletes or those
who are born with a high pain threshold
or is it people by being an athlete you
learn to have a higher pain yeah exactly
which which way is the arrow of
causality moving here yeah and my
default answer in these cases is that
it's there's probably a bit of both but
I
the strongest evidence is towards the
second idea that which is that by by
training on a regular basis you increase
your pain tolerance and and again this
isn't because you stop feeling pain it's
because you learn to cope with it you
develop psychological coping mechanisms
if you go to the gym every day and put
yourself through some discomfort you
gradually get better and better at
various things like distraction you get
better about thinking of thinking about
something else instead of just thinking
about how much something you know this
exercise hurts you also get better at
interpreting pain as information so
taking away the emotional response not
like this hurts I hate this this you
know this is a disaster you're just
thinking this hurts therefore this tells
me it gives me some information about
how hard I'm working and whether I can
continue for so it's almost related to
sort of mindfulness which is of course a
big buzzword these days but one of the
definitions of mindfulness is
non-judgmental self-awareness and by
exercising on a regular basis you start
to be able to be non-judgmentally aware
of pain it's just information it's not
it's not a signal that you're about to
die yeah I think a lot of people
especially when they get into pain if
they're if they're not used to training
they will begin to either push it away
or identify with it quite heavily
because it's such a foreign sensation
but the same as with anything if you are
acclimatized to it and you've been here
before
wherever here maybe then you'll be able
to deal with it
more comfortably yeah and I think mandir
stands that let's say you're a sedentary
person who's never who doesn't do any
exercise and you decide you want to run
a 5k with your friends in six months and
so you start a sort of run walk program
do a little training everyone
understands that in six months your body
will have changed that you will your
lungs will be more powerful your heart
will be stronger your muscles will be
more efficient what people don't realize
necessarily or I don't think give enough
credit to is that their mind will have
changed a lot too so when you start you
know and you have you're not familiar
with running you go out and do a bit of
running and pretty soon your legs start
to burn and you're panting heavily and
all sorts of alarm signals are going off
in your brain and you're thinking oh my
god this hurts so much I'm you know I'm
gonna put myself in hospital I need to
slow down and stop
but the more times you kind of hold your
finger near that flame the more you
realize oh I can hold it there and I'm
not gonna die so I can hold it a little
bit closer next time or hold it there
for a little bit longer
and over time I you you're actually
pushing your body much harder even
relative to your fitness so you're
getting fitter but you're also pushing
deeper into the well with experience and
and one important thing about that there
was a classic study in the early 80s
with Scottish the Scottish national
swimming team of all of all places where
they they measured pain tolerance not
just once but throughout a season and
what they found is with these elite
athletes had been you know training hard
for at least a decade in most cases
their pain tolerance waxed and waned
throughout the season so their pain
tolerance was highest right before their
our most important competitions and then
it was lowest in the offseason when they
weren't training so these were very
experienced athletes they'd spent plenty
of time in the pain cave but it still
wasn't a question of just like once you
learn to handle pain that's it
you know you now know and you've
mastered this trick you never need to
think about it again it's something that
you have to constantly work out every
day to remind yourself or not every day
necessarily but on a continuing basis
you you you have to keep teaching
yourself how to handle discomfort and if
you you know you've take a month off
then your body gets a little softer and
so but so does your mind yeah I think
there'll be a lot of CrossFitters
they're listening and some power lifters
and strength athletes as well and I
certainly think that of all of the
signals that our brain is receiving
which is influencing our rate of
perceived exertion pain will definitely
be one of the ones that's at the
forefront you know not enough oxygen
manifests itself as a painful breathing
and a discomfort and a lot of people
would probably confuse that being out of
breath with pain and the muscular burn
and a leg burn and you know all of these
things manifest is pain it sounds like
pain would probably be a pretty big
gatekeeper to a lot of performance for
sure and I think it's it's sort of like
I don't know being a wine lover a cheese
lover or something the more
sophisticated you get
the more you can distinguish between the
subtle flavors of pain said when you
start out it's just like holy crap is
very well everything hurts and it's all
the same it's all just one big pain you
know whereas once you've become
accustomed to it it's like ah I feel
that my let you know I feel the lactaid
in my legs oh and I think I'm going a
little bit hypoxic I'm running out of
oxygen and ooh I think I detect a subtle
undertone of you know muscular fatigue
or whatever so you to appreciate all the
the nuances of pain I totally get that I
mean anyone who's ever sat on an assault
bike and tried to slow down their
breathing as they're going maximally
will know that you can actually control
your breathing quite well you can focus
on breathing in and out rhythmically
breathing deep and controlling that but
that the pain in your legs doesn't stop
but the pain in your lungs
oddly does so you can actually if you
know if anyone is sitting on an assault
bike tomorrow I urge you try it do warm
up and then do 30 seconds of Max cows
but focus on breathing in for two and
out for two as deeply as you can and
you'll notice that you can control your
breathing up until the point which you
need to start to punt you can control
your breathing quite nicely but the pain
the pain in your legs doesn't go away
but you've been able to isolate the two
as opposed to like you say this it kind
of nebulous coating this glazing of just
discomfort that goes everywhere and with
familiar with familiarity as we begin to
isolate and and get familiar with them
they're less scary it's just it's
instead of this is one big sort of
unpleasant feeling we have all these
different sensations that we can like
you said we can control or move up and
down as desired and and yeah then you're
willing to to handle it for a little
longer for a little more brilliant so
let's get on to some of the I'm gonna
call them solutions but I guess that
they technically aren't some of the
tactics and some of the tools that you
discovered which can aid people with
regards to their endurance yeah so I
mean there are a bunch of techniques and
I mentioned awhile ago the electric
brain stimulation and there's that
there's that sort of approach
but I think and you know like we could
spend a lot of time talking about the
pros and cons of various different tools
like that but to me the underlying most
important thing if you want to get the
most out of yourself is actually to
manipulate basically your belief your
self belief that and this goes back to
what we were saying right Reno ready to
start at the show that if if you believe
you're capable of something it will
change fundamentally the way you go
about doing it and it will change your
experience of whether you think you're
capable of it it will change your
perception of effort and so how do you
change your belief well I you know you
can have a situation where the
timekeeper gives you the wrong time in a
race and it tricks you into thinking
that you're capable of more than you are
but that's not something you can control
so how do you do it in a controllable
way and you know another classic example
is you know one of the stories I tell in
the book is from a mentor of mine named
Andy Burfoot who was a former Boston
Marathon champion and he said the single
most important or most powerful workout
you can do as a runner is let's say you
do five times a mile as hard as you can
with two minutes break and when you're
finished that's a very hard workout when
you're finished lying there on the
ground you know it was a broken man if
your coach then says okay get up and do
one more at the same pace and you'll say
but I can't I just went all out and the
coach will say get out there and do it
and you get out there and discover that
oh wait I can do it once you know it
hurts but you did you do have one more
rep in the tank and and what Hamby
Burfoot says is that like from that
you'll discover that you're capable of
more than you think you are and that's
the the single most important lesson you
can learn in running so I think that's
powerful but it's again an example of
something that's you know it's not
something you could self administer not
a super controllable is it yeah you know
you even if you have a coach which most
of many of us don't who's willing to do
something like that it only works once
you know he's not gonna be your friend
after he does it exactly and so so you
have to you want to try and find
techniques that are a little bit more um
your control and and so for me this the
number one thing is is a technique
called motivational self-talk which is
basically just becoming aware of the
internal monologue in your head and
ensuring that it's positive so if you're
someone like me then if you go and run a
marathon the thoughts going through your
head tend to be along the lines of hey
you know this sucks I hate this sport
why do I do this to myself this is a
disaster I'm you know I'm gonna fail and
then you know when you're doing
something that's frankly as unpleasant
as running a marathon that that's pretty
normal to have those sorts of thoughts
running through your head but those are
basically the equivalent of the
subliminal picture of a frowning face on
the wall in front of you either they're
altering your mindset such that
everything feels a little bit harder so
you're hurting your performance and so
you want to be able to stop that
negative self-talk and replace it with
positive self-talk like you know I've
trained for this I'm ready for this like
I can do this and that sounds really
easy it sounds almost too easy
of course it it is challenging to you
you have to make that become automatic
you have to really find words or mantras
that work for you and you have to
practice them so they become automatic
so it's like you say it sounds super
easy but mean you're sat down in the
comfort of our seats speaking into
microphones and the listeners at home
got the headphones in maybe driving to
work and chilling out like do that after
the 5 by 1 mile workout that try and
remind yourself that no I can do this
and you know I like I'm on the floor
dying breathing gasping for air the it
exactly has changed you happy so you
have to have done it a thousand times in
not to unpleasant circumstances you know
in training before it can become
ingrained enough that you'll actually be
able to summon it successfully in
competition now this is I should
emphasize this is not a new idea right
like when again when I was in university
in the 1990s we had a sports
psychologist working with the track team
who basically taught us exactly that and
we totally laughed her out of the room
we thought it was ridiculous we just
didn't didn't give a hoot about you know
these these tricks or the what we saw as
you know just ridiculous mental games
and it's so it's only been sort of in
the
process of the sort of journey of trying
to understand the limits of endurance
I've started to take this more seriously
and then in the last few years there
have been some studies that really
rigorously try to assess motivational
self-talk and you know bring a bunch of
cyclists into the lab have them do a
endurance test give half of the
motivational self-talk training half of
them gives them some other sort of
control mental mental skills training
bring them back to the lab and you find
that yeah the ones who got motivational
self-talk have improved their
performance not only that we can measure
what's going on in their bodies and we
see that their core temperature they're
able to push it higher so in other words
they're they're digging deeper into
their physiological reserves and yet
their sense of effort is still the same
so by changing the words in their head
by changing what they're saying to
themselves during the exercise they've
actually changed the relationship
between how hard their body is working
and how hard it feels in their minds and
that is the that to me I saw that result
and I was like oh man I wish I had a
time machine and I could go back and
take this seriously when I was competing
nice because this is real it's real and
I should have taken it seriously instead
of laughing that poor woman out of the
room I totally get that so were there
any of the techniques we've talked about
the motivational self-talk is one of
them we're not going to strap 9-volt
batteries to our head this is not
medical advice please do not please seek
a physician before you at cetera
disclaimer disclaimer um were there any
others that could you know III almost
hate to mention the buzziest of buzz
words mindfulness training but there's
some pretty interesting research there
were some interesting research at UC San
Diego I visited some some researchers
there to see their work doing brain
scanning on basically they look at elite
performance so they've because they're
in San Diego they get a bunch of Marines
and Navy SEALs into their lab and also
they bring in elite athletes like
adventure racers and so these people
have tremendous resilience so pretty
hard people yeah yeah yeah they've been
through a lot and so Monnaie ting one of
their protocols is that they put you in
a brain scanner which is like a you know
big sort of claustrophobic tube and your
your your well your in the brain scanner
you're doing these cognitive tasks on a
computer so the testing your your your
responses and your breathing through a
mask and every once in a while the flow
of oxygen through the mask is restricted
so it's like you're suddenly like you're
breathing through a straw yeah this is
not a pleasant scenario when you're
locked in this giant magnet and so for
most people when that happens you know
at best they get stressed out and their
performance on the cognitive test
suddenly goes down how worse they panic
and they have to be pulled out of the
scanner for the for the elite
performance so for the Navy SEALs for
the elite adventure racers the opposite
pattern this happens not only feeling
not panic their performance on the
cognitive test actually gets better when
they're being stressed out by this by
breathing through a straw
so they respond to stress not by getting
worse but by getting better by rising to
the occasion so obviously that's that's
a really desirable thing it's like oh no
I want I want to become nothing Talib's
definition of any fragile piece exactly
so you know and they're doing brain
scans just to figure out which areas of
the brain are responsible and what they
find is that the elite performers
they're constantly monitoring how their
body is feeling so they have a low level
low level self monitoring going on at
all times and then that does when
something with you know when the
breathing goes wrong when it all gets
stressful they just keep that same level
of monitoring they're always in touch
with how they're feeling whereas most of
us have kind of have the self monitor
and turned off when everything's fine
were not even paying attention to how
we're feeling and then all of a sudden
when things go bad we over monitor we
ramp up to panic levels so we overreact
to the to the stimulus so and you can
see which areas of the brain are
responsible for that so then their
question is okay we know what the
quote-unquote good brain pattern of
brain activation is how can we help
other people develop that and and the
most effective tool they've found so far
is eight-week training courses in
mindfulness and so they've been testing
it out with US Marines being deployed
overseas giving them this eight-week
training beforehand to see if it reduces
instances for example of PTSD because if
you're able to respond calmly to
stressful situations that may reduce the
risk of post-traumatic stress so that
stuff is still up in the air and
research is ongoing but but it is
interesting they've found that you can
sort of generate these elite style brain
patterns with mindfulness training and
when you think about what mindfulness
training is it's you're trying to have
non-judgmental self-awareness so you're
trying to be aware of hey is my feeling
pain yes I'm not denying that I'm
feeling pain I'm aware of it I'm
acknowledging it but I'm not
overreacting to it and so that's kind of
what they're they find is the hallmark
of the elite performers and I think it
has a lot of application to what they
were talking about endurance to whether
we're talking about you know CrossFit or
whatever whatever the context I think
they're it's not too big of a leap to
say that would that would be an
effective way of enhancing performance
now I should say I'm sitting here again
as I said I'm sitting here and with my
comfortable chair saying that's what I
think would be a good idea based on the
research I haven't done an eight-week
mindfulness training course so I you
know I can't I can't speak from personal
experience but I think that's an avenue
that I would say is is worth exploring I
guess that that sort of stuff would work
across so many different domains as well
for traders Wall Street traders in very
very high-pressure situations and stuff
like that you talked about the fact that
this endurance is not not merely
relating to physical activities but to
all activities yeah exactly exactly that
brings a sort of full circle back to
this idea of endurance as a very
generalized struggle to continuous
continue against the momentum desire to
stop and and again I want to emphasize
that I didn't start out this book trying
trying to make endurance a general
concept really all I cared about was
trying to understand but you know that
sort of mysteries of my running career
and why I why I didn't go faster than I
did but but that's where the research
led that to suggest that it really is a
generalizable concept and then if you if
you can learn to endure and and and I
think it's interesting that again you
look at that the data for instance on
pain tolerance that athletes who are
enduring a specific kind of pain in
training doesn't matter what kind of
pain tolerance test you give them
whatever pain tolerance test you give
them they're better able to tolerance so
it's tolerated so it's very
generalizable you're able to apply these
you learn well pushing yourself
physically you're able to try apply
those in other areas of your life too so
it really is a bit of a superpower when
people talk about there being benefits
from physical practice being mental in a
mental practice crossing it over in a
physically it seems like there's some
real some real good evidence for that to
be the case yeah you know I think you'd
have have trouble finding any dedicated
exerciser who doesn't believe it's had
far-reaching effects on their on their
lives and I think I think the the
research you know backs that up as far
as I can tell amazing so before we go I
want to very very quickly nerd out about
the night breaking - Elliot cacio gay
thing because I want to know whether or
not you think that the two hour marathon
barrier will be broken and if so when it
will happen yeah so you know my record
of prognostication is not great Thank
You Bernie did you predict the Berlin
Marathon smash well in a way so let me
let me back up slightly and say in 2014
I run this world had me do a big 10 page
report on the physiology of what it
would take to run a two hour marathon
and so I spent all sorts of time talking
to every expert I could find and in the
end at the end of those 10 pages I need
this prediction that I thought the two
hour marathon 2 hour marathon barrier
could be broken and it would be broken
in 2075 so that's a long time from now
and so they're you know two years later
I got this we got this call from Nike
say you know basically saying we're
gonna try and do it next May do you want
to come along for the ride and and you
know report on it and so might you know
my initial thought when that happened
was man one of us was gonna look really
stupid
one of us is gonna look bad so so take
take my predictions with a grain of salt
but so what what then what happened with
the braking - project which was this
multi-million dollar multi-year attempt
to sort of engineer an ideal marathon is
that Elia kept show gear an two hours 0
minutes 25 seconds which was not sub 2
but was faster than the official world
record by two and a half minutes so it
was didn't count as a world record
because he had paid pacing all the way
through which isn't allowed but but
still it sort of showed that a human
could run that fast which was really
shocking so after that happened my
prediction here's one of my predictions
get a little better so that was in May
of 2017 breaking to happens so I said le
Kip Jogi just ran this almost two hour
marathon so I think in an official
marathon even though he won't have all
the same benefits that he got from the
breaking to race I think he's going to
run 201 something which would be more
than a minute faster than the the the
official world record and so I made that
prediction in a big New York Times op-ed
just before the Berlin Marathon in 2017
it's called putting your balls on the
line yeah I said and then what happened
was it rained in Berlin and so he ran a
great race but you know in the rain it
was slow he didn't break the world
record he didn't know forget to a1 he
didn't even break to a four or two a
three rather and then so his next
marathon was in London earlier this year
in early early 2018 and he it was the
hottest London Marathon in history so he
ran a great race and he won again but he
didn't run under the world record and so
at that point I thought oh man he first
I predicted 2075 then I predicted 200 on
something and they're both going to be
good but then in September 2018 kept
shogi finally got a decent weather day
and he ran 201 39 which was a minute and
18 seconds faster than the world record
which is a huge shoots the biggest image
in 50 years or something isn't it
exactly so a huge huge huge improvement
and I got to say to everyone I predicted
a 201 in Berlin it was last year but
still give me a break yeah it's close
enough close enough so yeah so what
happens next
it's hard to know it's it because
there's there's all these questions
about so how much of this is Elliot kept
shogi being a once-in-a-generation
talent how much of it is these got these
new shoes from Nike which are you have a
carbon-fiber plate and then they're
supposed to people make people 4% faster
how much you know what are all the
different ingredients that make made up
his world record and nobody knows for
sure I don't know you know nobody
you knows for sure so the question is it
will someone else follow Kip Jogi into
the sort of 202 or 201 range or scoop
chogi gonna be a guy who's mark stands
for 15 years but if I had to predict I'm
gonna say now that we're at 201 I think
the chorus of voices who would have said
even 3 years ago who would have said 2
hours will never happen in our lifetime
you guys are all morons I think that
chorus is is just hearing and instead
now I don't know I still think probably
10 to 20 years from now but boy you know
I would not put any money that I wanted
to see again on any prediction because I
just don't know what's gonna happen so I
you know I wouldn't bet against another
big improvement I also wouldn't bet
against it sort of stagnating for a
while
yeah it's bizarre isn't it when you
think over such a long distance over two
hours of running that we're talking
about shaving off 25 seconds and that
that margin feels like such a huge
mountain to climb
and it's obviously because you know I've
anyone who hasn't I urged them to watch
the breaking 2 documentary it's on
YouTube and it's absolutely fascinating
but Elliot Kip show gay lives this
monastic lifestyle very very simplistic
guy seems super calm all the time and he
looks like the sort of person who has
dialed every singer he looks like
someone that was born to run yeah I
would I would a hundred percent echo the
encouragement to check out that National
Geographic documentary on breaking 2
because it really is a taste of not just
what sort of science and tech was
involved in this race but led cryptokeys
personality the guy has become and I you
know I say this as a journalist I'm
supposed to keep my distance but the
guy's become my hero like his as my sort
of life model in terms of his approach
to life and I really sincerely believe
that his mindset his self-confidence in
the way he has nurtured it is in his own
way accomplishing everything that I have
written about in my book everything
we've talked about today like
motivational self-talk none of that has
anything to teach you Kip Jogi it's the
other way around we're kind of we're
trying to be figure out a little bit of
what makes him
so magic and how the rest of us can can
learn to push ourselves a little more
like he does but to me he's the he's the
Zen master I couldn't agree more what a
beautiful note to finish on Alex today
has blown my mind I'm sure we'll have
made a lot of the listeners at home
think very differently about the way
that they look at their endurance and
and their mind and body connection
during training and in other pursuits as
well would you be able to tell the
listeners at home where they can find
you online I'll make sure the link to
the book and all of your socials are in
the show notes below of course for sure
thanks yeah so probably the best place
to find me is on twitter my handle is
sweat science all one word and that's
where you know recent articles and
anything I find interesting I post I do
have a website Alex Hutchinson dotnet
where you can you know dig into my
sordid past
but yeah Twitter's a good place to find
me fantastic Alex I really appreciate
your time today it's been awesome thanks
so much Chris this was really fun to
kind of dig into some of the deeper
stuff thank you very much catch later
[Music]